الامريكي كعمله رئيسيه في العالم والتجاره
الدوليه قد يهتز ما هو السبب ان تحالف
بريكس الذي يضم خمس دول من بينهم الصين
والهند يحاول تغيير ذلك وبدات هذه
المحاولات في الظهور داخل الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا تحاول الصين بناء نفوذا
الدبلوماسي لمواجهه هيمنه الدول المتقدمه
في الامم المتحده والمنظمات العالميه
وتقود دول بريكس للتوسع في الشرق الاوسط
وتعزيز التبادل التجاري غير المعتمد على
الدولار الامريكي هدف الدول الخمس القضاء
على هيمنه الدولار في التبادلات التجاريه
الدوليه وهو ما قد يفيد على وجه خاص دول
الشرق الاوسط التي لديها تبادل تجاري ضخم
مع روسيا والصين وفق تقرير لشبكه سي ان ان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات